what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we run over all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week we're
largely sticking to marvel comic book
movies this week but for all of you guys
who are huge hugh jackman fans and want
to see him in the mcu do we have some
news for you but before we get into that
tom hardy has been actively campaigning
to get tom holland into the venom movies
or to do a movie with venom in a
tomahawk spider-man movie one way or the
other he's been campaigning to work with
tom holland and this is cool this is
something that we're seeing more and
more often in comic book films have you
guys noticed that they usually have
these kind of like separate universes
and that you had like tom holland who
didn't want to go back to just this sony
verse he wanted to say in the mcu so he
literally called up disney's president
drunk do you guys remember that it was
like the big to-do when it came out but
he literally called him up drunk just
like going on a rant about how he didn't
want to stay at sony he wanted to stay
in the mcu and apparently it worked it's
what led to the big deal between sony
and disney in the first place but now
you've got tom hardy who wants to have a
movie with tom holland and that's cool i
really like the idea that actors and
actresses are having a pretty big say in
how things progress with regards to the
marvel cinematic universe versus the
sony landscape i do believe it is kind
of making things a little complicated
how much i wish that things could just
be simple so we could go to see marvel
movies and we could see tom hall and
spider-man and not have to worry that he
won't be in the mcu in three years
but he'll basically be in there forever
but such is the deal sony currently owns
the film rights for spider-man but on
the same topic of venom a lot of you
guys may have also heard venom has been
delayed yet again it's been delayed only
by three weeks but apparently this is
due to rises in the delta variant of
covet now this is also kind of a
dangerous thing here the reason being
because if the movie was postponed due
to the rise in delta variant cases there
doesn't really seem to be any indication
those cases are going to go down and so
it seems like either going to stay even
or they're going to go up which means
the movie could be delayed yet again now
to be honest it makes sense that they're
doing this and the reason why is because
sony doesn't really seem to be doing
what disney's doing which is releasing
movies on disney plus and in the movie
theaters at the same time sony largely
seems to be sticking to the tried and
true formula of releasing the movies in
theaters and then once they have their
theatrical run then releasing them on
streaming services whatever those
services happen to be i'm not 100 sure
if sony has its own streaming service
i'm not going to swear to that and
honestly i'm too lazy to look it up
actually you know what that's not an
accurate statement i don't care enough
to look it up but regardless sony's
releasing the movie in theaters and so
if you want to maximize the amount of
money you can make in theaters because
this really seems to be their one shot
to recoup the money that was spent
making the film and then make a little
more money on top you want to keep it in
theaters so they're going to keep
postponing it hopefully not too long
otherwise interest will just die down
that's one of those things you really
have to contend with if you keep
postponing a movie long enough it just
won't perform well in the box office
because people will just stop caring and
as much as i love the first venom movie
and as excited as i am for venom 2 with
everything coming out next year it's
going to be a hard sell to get people to
care about a movie that's been postponed
multiple times in the face of everything
else that's coming out as well but
continuing our discussion here on comic
book movies did you guys see that in the
newest little tv spot i guess this
little one minute long teaser for shang
chi and legend of the 10 rings that we
finally got a much better look at
abomination when it's not an all grainy
pixelated image that's on like every
single website and everybody's using
photoshop adjustments to try to make it
look better we got a much cleaner image
of abomination and honestly he looks
kind of different from what he
originally looked like when we saw him
in the first incredible hulk film he
looks more like his comic book
counterpart now and i'm digging that the
funny thing about this and the question
that a lot of people probably end up
asking here is why does he look
different in all honesty i don't really
think marvel needs to provide an answer
for that right in the same way that the
incredible hulk as it's played or as
it's portrayed by mark ruffalo in the
mcu does not look the same as the
incredible hulk that we saw in the
edward norton film and people are just
kind of like yeah whatever it's the
incredible hulk and they just kind of
shrug their shoulders and call it a day
that you can do the same thing with
abomination if they really really want
to do an in-movie explanation they could
say that he's kind of evolved in terms
of his physical form right that when he
first became abomination it's like when
you're born into the world and over time
your body changes and then you become
essentially the person you're going to
look like more or less for the rest of
your life it's cool right it's an
interesting little concept there so it's
not the end of the world if they don't
explain it and if they choose to pretty
easily understood but i am very excited
about the fact that abomination looks so
much like as kind of a counterpart
because to be honest abomination always
look cool and can i be the one out here
and i feel like i'm not the only one but
i want to be the one out here to say i
am so excited about the fight between
wong and abomination oh my god dude that
fight is going to be amazing because
we've never really seen one go ham in
like the mcu right it's like jenna
marbles once said not only is ham
delicious you can go it and i want to
see wong go ham in the mcu man i want to
see that happen wong and abomination and
occasion it's like a pay-per-view thing
right like tomorrow night on
pay-per-view wong versus abomination
which one wins obviously wong is gonna
win but it looks cool right i'm really
excited to see this fight between these
two guys but continuing on it was
revealed that the director for thor 4
has really come out and said that a
component for the thor 4 film and
seemingly a big component is going to be
a love story now it's not going to be
the biggest focus and in fact i doubt
you're probably going to see a love
story between jane foster and thor maybe
you will but if i'm being honest with
you guys and i've kind of always wanted
to see this a love story between thor
and valkyrie and it seems like it
wouldn't work right but i kind of want
to see like like thor and tessa thompson
get together and just kind of be a
couple like i feel like it would be
really really awesome i don't know why i
keep saying thor chris hemsworth and
tessa thompson it's not like chris
hemsworth is thor
or is he
but regardless
[Laughter]
i really want to see the the romance
between the two of them if i'm being
honest with you guys i feel like a
really good way to make this work is if
because thor comes out next year and
then guardians three comes out the year
after something that i think would be
really cool to make this work is you
kind of build up the romance between
like thor and tessa thompson so like
midway through the film or three
quarters of the way through the film
they like kiss and then like officially
become a couple and then at the end of
the film it's like maybe a post-credits
scene or something like that she gets
snatched up by adam warlock and then
adam warlock is the main villain for
guardians 3 because we know that thor
and the guardians are going to be
together in in thor 4. so it would make
sense if they're basically two halves of
the same movie like infinity war in
avengers in game and here's the reason
why i say that those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with adam warlock and marvel
comics adam warlock was originally
called him and he was created by a group
called the enclave basically a group
that wanted to conquer the world through
technological means but they created
adam warlock to be the perfect human a
whole bunch of stuff happened fantastic
four was involved adam warlock
ultimately escaped one of the things
that he did is he longed for a companion
so he basically ended up kidnapping sith
who at the time was the girlfriend of
thor and then him and thor got into a
great big huge fight and then ultimately
the day was saved and everything was
kind of cool and then adam warlock went
back to do his own thing but i feel like
that'd be a cool component to put into
the mcu that instead of having sif that
what you basically have is tesla
thompson valkyrie that adam warlock
shows up on the scene snatches up tesla
thompson and it's like oh my god it's
like when bowser steals steals princess
speech and mario's gotta go save her
that like thor grabs the guardians and
says okay that's our next mission to be
continued in guardians three and they
race off to save uh valkyrie from adam
warlock and then you've got your main
villain already baked in for the first
or really for guardians of the galaxy
three i feel like that would be cool
right i mean i don't know if that would
definitively be the case i feel like
we're one we're not going to see uh adam
warlock and thor 4. we already know that
we know that he's supposed to debut in
guardians 3. so i feel like it kind of
works and trying to tie that plot into
thor 4 even if you do that in the third
act it's just a little too much for a
singular movie right you guys get what i
mean so i feel like kind of starting
that plot thread at the very end of thor
4 and continuing it in guardians of the
galaxy 3 would work pretty well but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section right if you guys think
that'd be cool or if you think it's just
it's a little too much and a little too
far-fetched but continuing on daniel
espinoza in a recent interview daniel
espinoza of course being the director
for the mobius film had basically
revealed this idea of being involved
with morbius and the possibilities of
what the mcu may do and it talked about
how when he was on the set walking
around he was running over the names of
people who had been on the set one of
those names was tom hardy now the
significance of that we don't fully know
but the fact that tom hardy is playing
venom and the fact that tom hardy was on
the set of the morbius film is
interesting it begs a few questions
right was tom hardy there is kind of an
advisor is tom hardy just a really good
friend of somebody like giorletto and he
was just kind of hanging out watching
him act honestly i think it's because
tom hardy is going to have a role in
morbius and that makes perfect sense
we've known for a long long time that
marvel's building up to the midnight
suns we've known that for quite some
time and while the traditional roster of
the midnight suns may or may not be seen
in the marvel cinematic universe in the
case of michael morbius and like ghost
rider and werewolf by night that if they
do decide to shift up a couple
characters and throw venom onto the team
that it would work because venom was
originally a pretty dark character so he
fit in really really well with the
midnight suns that kind of darker
element the one thing that venom lacks
that's not really part of the
traditional midnight sun's mythos is the
kind of dark horror side of marvel
comics which is really where the
midnight suns largely originated from
they were largely based on the concept
of like monsters from hollywood so like
you had mummy you had frankenstein you
had the werewolf different things like
that marvel comics very much copy that
with the midnight suns michael morbius
as a vampire werewolf by night
as a werewolf like these different kinds
of characters that you saw in the in
marvel comics it just kind of
represented the traditional horror side
that had long since been a part of
hollywood and so even if venom kind of
lacks that to a degree the movies as
they've been made by sonny or at least
the first one and presumably the second
one have been pretty dark so sure he
doesn't really represent any kind of
horror aspect of traditional hollywood
or even just writing in general right
just traditional uh literature but
regardless he would still fit in pretty
well with the midnight sun so i love the
idea that even if he's not necessarily
having a role in the movie that if mom
was like hey we're doing the midnight
suns so you know tom hardy sony you guys
go over there keep an eye on what's
going on because whatever it is that
happens to michael morbius is going to
affect the future of venom with regards
to the movies he's making as a part of
the sony verse and their crossover with
the mcu so you know we're gonna need you
to be abreast of what's going on
i love that idea right i love that kind
of that kind of coming together and
crossing over but for our final topic
here on to hugh jackman now what hugh
jackman had to say was massive there was
a recent interview that hugh jackman did
where he was talking about the idea of
playing wolverine in the mcu now yes
hugh jackman shot down the idea but not
in the way that you think historically
whenever hugh jackman was asked the
question are you going to play wolverine
in the mcu when's the time coming when
you're going to play wolverine in the
mcu it's always well no no that's not
really going to happen you know that's
not really my thing i'm done with the
character of wolverine nope this was
totally different so in this interview
he had basically said a couple different
things the first and probably the the
less significant here is that when he
was playing logan he just kind of had
this feeling that's it right this is
when he's done playing the character of
wolverine because the movie had a kind
of finality to it right not necessarily
even just for wolverine but for the fox
x-men universe as a whole right this is
when it's all basically done we did get
that terrible x-men dark phoenix movie
but honestly no one remembers it because
it sucked so don't worry if if you don't
remember that it exists or if you didn't
know it exists if you haven't seen it
you're probably doing yourself a massive
favor there but at the end of the day
like
hugh jackman kind of said this is the
this is it but it has a finality to it
it's done in the same way that like
avengers in game almost kind of had a
finality to the mcu that if fighting all
them said okay now we're done making
marvel movies it would have just felt
right it would have been disappointing
but it would have felt right it wouldn't
have felt like it was cut off
prematurely it would have been like
yeah i could see this is a good place to
end it seems like a good place to stop
right it would make sense the other
thing he said here and this is the more
significant thing is he did not say
i don't want to play wolverine in the
mcu i'm done playing the character of
wolverine i've had enough of it what he
said is i haven't gotten anything from
kevin feige yet and so until that
happens there's no reason to believe
that i'm not playing wolverine in the
mcu what does this mean that's a wholly
different statement from saying i don't
want to play the character it's just i
haven't been invited to yet all of that
reeks of the fact that hugh jackman's
interested in returning as wolverine in
the mcu he just hasn't heard anything
back from from kevin feige that confirms
that he's going to play wolverine in the
mcu let me tell you guys something man
as excited as the internet is about like
the spider-man no way home trailer let
the trailer for the x-men drop let the
trailer for the x-men come out and like
at the very end right you get like you
know the crazy action sequences and all
that kind of stuff and you guys know how
it goes the screen goes black and then
you get like this five second moment and
then like it's the end thing right like
coming out and such and such or whatever
and like that five second moment is just
like some claws pop and then you see
hugh jackman's face and it's cut to
black let me tell you something man the
internet would [ __ ] explode if that
happened dude it would go nuts i could
tell you right now man i would freak i'd
probably destroy my own set and
excitement yes i know it doesn't make
any rational sense we're human beings
we're naturally irrational i would freak
i would you guys would never ever see me
lose my mind as much as you would see me
lose it if we saw hugh jackman if we had
a trailer and hugh jackman appeared in
the trailer for the x-men in the mcu and
it's like
yeah
he's back as wolverine dude i would i
would freak i want to know how would you
guys react how would you guys respond if
you saw the trailer for the x-men in the
mcu and then it was revealed in that
trailer that hugh jackman's returning at
wolverine what would you do right how
would you react i really really need to
know that i'm going to be going through
all your comments because i'm really
hoping i would see people who would just
be like in all caps i would freak
i really hope you guys type that in the
comments i would freak i really hope you
guys do but regardless like i'd be super
excited but with that being said guys
that's our episode of the rumor roundup
for this week thank you guys for tuning
in let us know in the comments if there
was any news that you feel like we
missed and we will catch you all later
peace